after the army of Northern Virginia
delivered another major victory at
second Manassas Lee seized on the
Strategic initiative by moving across
the Potomac River and taking the war to
the loyal North
Lee wasted very little time after second
Manassas in preparing to go into
Maryland and his decision was shaped by
several factors
first he put his faith in the offensive
as the best chance to achieve a victory
of annihilation over Union armies
he also sought logistical relief for the
Confederate home front given that
Northern and Central Virginia had been
occupied by armies with voracious
appetites for food and fodder
both sides had dismantled fences for
campfires and fortifications confiscated
livestock trampled crops and drunk the
wells dry
heading north might also fill his empty
ranks with new recruits
Maryland had many Southern sympathizers
mostly in Eastern Maryland but Lee's
army was headed into unionist-dominated
Western Maryland
his soldiers were bitterly disappointed
when marylanders did not greet them as
liberators
politics likewise motivated Lee if he
could win a decisive Victory on Northern
soil perhaps it would influence the fall
Congressional elections in the North
Democrats might well take control of
Congress which could possibly lead to an
Armistice and a peace settlement
finally Lee thought that Battlefield
success might gain foreign support for
the Confederacy especially from Great
Britain and France
given these factors on September 4th
only five days after the victory at
second Manassas the army of Northern
Virginia crossed the Potomac at whites
Ford into Maryland and headed toward
Frederick
there Lee decided on the course of his
action
he needed to run his supply line back
into Virginia's Shenandoah Valley but
the enemy's occupation of Harper's Ferry
stood in the way
Lee decided to divide his forces
dispatching Jackson with more than half
the Army to capture the twelve thousand
man Union Garrison at Harpers Ferry
the remainder of the Confederate Army
would move deeper into Maryland toward
Hagerstown
dividing his smaller Army before the
army of the Potomac was extraordinarily
risky even with McClellan as the
opponent
Lee's plan issued a special orders 191
was put into operation and all the
Confederates marched away from Frederick
in different directions
but the campaign quickly began to
unravel
first the Army suffered miserably from
large-scale straggling and desertion
some of the men had not signed up to
fight on Northern soil and refused to
cross the Potomac
others had busted shoes threadbare
uniforms and empty haversacks
the active campaigning since August had
taken a toll
food was also scarce and soldiers were
largely living on green apples and green
corn
chronic diarrhea ripped through the
ranks
approximately 65 000 Confederates had
crossed the Potomac but by Lee's own
estimates a third to half of his army
fell out of the ranks during the
campaign
this was an enormous rate of attrition
Lee's concerns grew when he realized
that McClellan was moving with
uncharacteristic speed
the union General's confidence received
a boost when some Indiana soldiers
kicking through the debris left in an
abandoned Confederate camp discovered
some papers wrapped around three cigars
the papers were an extra set of the
orders that had been sent to General D.H
Hill
holding up the plans McClellan announced
here is a piece of paper with which if I
cannot whip Bobby Lee I will be willing
to go home
McClellan pressed his 102 thousand man
army to the West and his troops seized
control of the gaps in South Mountain on
September 14th
a day later Harper's Ferry fell to
Jackson and Lee decided to concentrate
his army on The High Ground overlooking
Antietam Creek near Sharpsburg
by the morning of the 17th Lee had
between 30 000 and 35 000 troops in
place
leaving One Division under AP Hill back
in Harpers Ferry
McClellan however turned cautious after
South Mountain
instead of strikingly scattered forces
he inched his army towards Sharpsburg on
the 15th and the next day he moved some
troops across Antietam Creek at dusk
with the first morning light on
September 17th mcclellan's men would
initiate the bloodiest day in the
American Civil War
[Music]
so Carrie we've established that Lee's
army was depleted in its March through
Northern Virginia across Potomac and
into Maryland but with those fewer
numbers Lee he always had an eye for
terrain could you describe for us the
ground that he held by Antietam Creek on
the morning of September 17th absolutely
so Lee is west of Antietam Creek he's
occupying The High Ground along
Hagerstown Pike his army is spread out
for about two and a half miles the left
is anchored on a ridge near Nicodemus
farm and then it will pass through a
cornfield belonging to David R Miller
and then that that part of the line will
be anchored along a plateau where you
can today go visit the dunker Church a
prominent White Church on the
battlefield a church of pacifist which
is a church of pacifist which is
incredibly perhaps ironic considering
this this horrific battle that's going
to take place there then the rest of his
line proceeding to the South part of it
that the center of the line will be
anchored along a sunken Road it's an Old
Farm Lane that had been used so much
that it had fallen below grade in many
places it was running East-West and then
the the far right will be farther down
to the South near a bridge that would
become known as burnside's Bridge
so McClellan is back in command he's
he's always been in command to the army
of the Potomac but now he has this full
force with him again what is his plan at
Antietam
historians have a very difficult time
Discerning what he intended to do on the
morning of September 17th but I think
everyone is in agreement that McClellan
always worked from an assumption and
that assumption is that he was always
badly outnumbered and he thought that
Lee's army was maybe in the range of a
hundred thousand men and certainly Lee
didn't have more than 50
000 but maybe 45
000 but that was never mccollin's
working assumption and so every decision
that he made prior to the battle and
during the battle is that fear that he
is outnumbered now he did intend to
strike the Confederate Left Flank that
Left Flank anchored in the area of the
dunker Church which you just described
that opening salt was led by Joseph
Hooker Joseph Hooker was a man who was
extraordinarily aggressive he's also a
man who was very ambitious politically
but he knew how to deliver assault the
attack I'm about to describe the very
first assault and one in which you can
in fact stand at the edge of the North
Woods the park service has done a
brilliant job of restoring the three
main wood Lots on the Confederate Left
Flank the Northwoods that's the jumping
off point four hookers attack there's
the eastwoods and then there's the
Westwoods you can stand at the
Northwoods today you can follow the
route of hooker's men and the details
here are important I believe they're
important because they help us
understand why Civil War assaults often
unraveled and they unravel not because
generals were incompetent it's just
called the fog of War
so there are three brigades that hooker
had under his command to make that
opening assault those three brigades
together probably in the range of six
thousand men the idea is they Advance
toward that dunker church and they hit
the Confederate line with one
concentrated blow when the salt began of
those three brigades only one made it
only one made it to strike the
Confederates the other two one commanded
by an officer named Christian
uh he became unnerved by the artillery
fire he walked away from his command a
Second Officer named heartsuff was hit
by a shell fragment he's wounded the
command obviously halted the third
Brigade duries Brigade is the only one
that made it through the famous
cornfield the initial fighting didn't
happen in the cornfield it happened on
the edge of the cornfield and they ran
duries man smack into a Confederate line
that initiated a series of attacks back
and forth the fighting's extraordinarily
fluid and you gotta go to the field you
gotta walk that ground and you'll come
to appreciate why the fighting was so
Savage and why the casualties were so
intense there is no need for us to go
over all those movements I think what
people need to imagine again is that one
side has an upper hand and just when
they're about to deliver that knockout
blow reinforcements arrive on the other
side and it goes back and forth and back
and forth It's about nine o'clock when
the fighting ended on that part of the
Confederate Left Flank and the
casualties total cash cities about eight
thousand men just in that that short
period of time in that first phase
[Music]
foreign